[Musica]
no
oggi su
[Musica]
aspettatemi bene bene non potevo farla
ieri sera perché mi hanno tolto il
cerotto quindi ho rimandato una live per
un cerotto yeah
comunque volevo dirvi che tra un po tra
un po non farò più live la domenica ma
ve lo dirò più avanti
sto cambiando un sacco di roba per te
per andare incontro a youtube si vedono
trovando un sacco di roba quindi
tranquilli tranquilli una sega tra un po
ci saranno un sacco di cambiamenti vabbè
vabbè come sta ha detto a posto
sì va bene si sente bene non ci sono
problemi non ci sono problemi strano non
ci siano problemi nel milan ci sono
sempre problemi
tutto giusto boh strano vabbè allora
ragazzi oggi si fa un gioco che ho fatto
tre volte nella mia vi con questa
compresa stavolta l'ho fatto tre volte
però non me lo ricordo ci avvicino ce
l'ho fatta prima volta tipo sei anni fa
sette anni fa poi l'ho rifatto due anni
fa su questo sul canale ovviamente e ho
detto raga lo rifaccio perché non
ricordo più
no non mi ricordo chi di nuovo faccio di
no no va beh in realtà è perché volevo
fare un qualcosa tema horror la sera
cioè intorno ad halloween insomma oro
farlo ad halloween poi ho detto va bene
dallo vi faccio qualcosa con i miei
amici non faccio lo sfigato quindi vabbè
ho deciso di fare questa cosa un po così
suoni quindi spero che siate tutti con
ben di dire che possiamo iniziare anche
perché sono andiamo troppo troppo avanti
tanto non dura tantissimo penso di fare
anche mira ogni visto che dura poco
quanto dura l'aiba fino a mezzanotte in
teoria secondo me entro mezzanotte
dovrei riuscire a finire sia honey siani
raonic
in teoria è in teoria
vabbè iniziamo iniziamo grazie mille
giorgio samuele manuel umberto starling
per la donazione grazie anche a nicolas
queste lai tattiche 5 caffè per te caro
un bacino grazie dicono secondo gentile
va bene se pronti allora io ho scaricato
animi ronnie non solo messo allora ci
pensiamo dopo
togliamo la musica atmosfera horror
secondo me mi conviene fare meglio così
sì perché da più in quella sensazione di
buio ci stavano dai ci siete allora io
non mi ricordo niente non mi ricordo
niente so che siamo tutti quanta gente
c'è ragazzi io farò le live di sera ve
lo dico perché parte che youtube pian
piano si sta sbagliando bugs bagarre
sempre per essere più trasparenti
possibile quindi non so se si iniziano a
contare gli sul serio e gli spettatori
però va bene entro mezzanotte più o meno
dovrei uscire finire aoni eni raoni in
teoria in teoria
se riuscita state finanziate bene se no
tranquilli che tanto la live rimane
online
per il resto dei tempi finché l'umanità
non cesserà di esistere
allora visto che già che siamo in un
horror magari tolgo queste cose
l'elettricità attorno alle mie orecchie
visto che magari distoglie l'attenzione
e facciamo facciamo così ciao andrich
ti ricordi che sono però poche mete
racconti youtube e non possiedo puoi
iscriverti io non fossi scrivi tu non
puoi scrivere io non possessori e non
puoi non ho capito quello che mi hai
detto pero grazie grazie
non ho capito ma grazie hendrix molto
gentile ragazzi allora io sono una sega
negli horror tipo questi perché non so
mai mimì incastro perché è un horror
tipo ci sono polinik mi quindi dovreste
dare una mano in teoria
su determinate cose se mi date una mano
quando mi inchiodo in certi punti e
tutto che ha apprezzato quindi ragazzi
datemi la mano grazie ciao lexus che i
ricordini mette in contatto nel 2000 17
la tua firma si che mi ricordo di te
cavolo sei l'unica persona che mi ha
chiesto una firma nel 2017 quindi è
ovvio la lexus che sei tu quella persona
grazie della donazione sia molto gentile
un bacino grazie si può ora grazie bit
grazie gabrieli
se però anti io non so se semin three
però spurs però speriamo di no qual è il
nome del protagonista
hiroshi ha già ok questa è però che tu
puoi mettere il nome della persona
chiamiamoci pino pino così o pinotto in
maiuscolo grazie andrich se poi io video
visti ai quindi era giusto io mi dove
scriva bemis farcela live mi iscrivo ok
allora tagliamo avevo il mio amico di
seguire ok grazie laila ti chiamava iv a
b j bene poiché denunciata per copyright
grazie mille c'è grazie una sega però
c'è per i cinque ragazzi ciao arcangelo
ciò gli uni la ciao daniele pino let's
roll
atmosfera horror miss di fa abbiamo
sentito le voci di una villa fuori città
di una villa questa villa
dicono che sia abitata da un mostro non
si vede è vero che non si vede che palle
non si vede o ma cos'è sta roba che ogni
volta e vedi che siamo ragione quando
dicevo che c'erano problemi ogni volta
che facciamo o non si vede o li mortacci
miei alla fama così guarda che si fanno
prima
ecco la top come si zooma in questi
programmi per proprio youtubers zoom
zoom
mamma mia si raga in quattro terzi
quindi si vede così ma che posso farci
niente lo aspetta un attimo write
ecco a posto si vede adesso siete
contenti facciamo che però per
amalgamare lo sfondo visto che si vede
il mio desktop facciamo che scarica una
foto di pino insegno di black in black
diciamo così aspetta un attimo che
arrivo
lei
riuscirò a scaricare un'immagine nera ne
facciamo così va rottamato gimp
programmi per i pro e youtube herz
allora tac tac
ecco qua ciao
abbiamo qua ho aperto un immagine mi sta
crescendo il computer vi dico solo
questo perfetto ecco sfondo nero
tutti contenti le sue vabbè ce la farai
notato che il video di ben di dura 4
mentis infatti l'ho tolto adesso polo
ricarico piazze della donazione
l'ho tolto va beh non so perché durava
dato ha avuto un problema quindi paul
ricard
ciao giada ciao liuni la ciao peppe modo
sentivo bene partiti anzi li facciamo
come se non avessi fatto niente li
facciamo sì
gioco qual è il nome del protagonista
non è hiroshi rifacciamo di nuovo la
rifaccio st scena così a me non si vede
per tutti mi sono chiamato pino il buon
vino
sempre negli horror secondi
io ci ho già caldo loriaux abbiamo
sentito le voci di una villa fuori città
dicono che sia abitato da un mostro è
molto più carina all'interno basse
dentisti arredamenti non li sto vedendo
io zia vero barba bene e più carina così
sono io qui fa davvero freddo si 6
tullio c'è un caldo best tours usciamo
di qua va bene cosa c'è che non va
takeshi paura foro da gashi di coca e
casca un piatto miglia se sei a casa mia
vita mi cascano in cinque minuti
così stupido non è possibile che i
nostri esistano è scientificamente
impossibile ei pino perché sono chiamato
il filo è bellissimo c'è smorza di
brutto l'oro e ip non stai attento
sono già partiti va beh
cosa pensi spalle nel processo 4 allora
e bello però l'ho interrotto perché a me
non piacciono gli supereroi cielo il
giocatore fighissimo meglio a me non
piace propri supereroi sosta malattia
quindi non riesco a far piacere però è
un bel gioco per carità io sto giocando
a radente redemption grazie agostino
grazie andric di nuovo ciao grazie
giulia e santiago per le donazioni dai
partiamo la porta è chiusa
questo il piatto 8 che sono ricordavo
non mi ricorderò mai tutto mai però ve
la scassare la scritta in
sovraimpressione pino c'è un piatto
rotto a terra ho trovato l'oggetto
scheggia di piatto fondo cielo per culo
ma ok progetti nemico di tas scheggia di
piatto tasti raga io devo salvare
randomicamente c'è salvo io si corre con
ma si può correre mi ricordo niente
raga trovata una scheggia di piatto è
però siete stronzi e solo perché mi
chiamo pino perché la gente mi abbandona
così ragazzi verrà tutti ragazzi non so
non ho idea del perché la gente sia così
fronda con me non si apre
ma dai allora usciamo da questa casa
sono sicuro che la porta si aprirà
ma guardate che coincidenza incredibile
non si apre wow non avrei mai detto
la vista anche lei nonna nonna sei tu
non si apre e meno male aggiungerei o ma
si apre qualcosa questa casa di me
regala un assenso non ricordavo così le
porte ci hanno le maniglie e usa le
tribù york questa roba se starò a una
piantina della casa sembrano disegni di
scatole della piantina della casa bene o
questo sì aperte fino cioè armadio col
parkinson
ah no c'è sul sito nell'armadio forse ha
sì ecco infatti i numeri gordo ciao ciao
takeshi già takeshi questo qualche a gas
83 takeshi minchia se fossi 2 avere le
redini del mondo saremo nella merda beh
sembra un po donald trump da john era
quindi ci stava anche l'esempio pesci 3
ma in realtà impostato vibrazione non è
che trema lui e dove sono gli altri
scommetto che adesso trema guarda non
avrei mai detto se veramente d'aiuto
takeshi un po come io quando mi
chiedevano consigli durante le verifiche
di matematica takeshi mio io ti lascio
lì scommetto che trema ancora wow
finirai di tremare un po che bello avere
degli amici che ti ti aiutano e che
stanno l'onta vicini ma io sono prima e
salverò la situazione si vede bene si
sente bene raga che dovrò andare avanti
tutta la live così quindi non si vede
bene so cazzi
la porta è chiusa guardate
me l'aspettavo mai parcheggi skas sia
effettivamente non si non si apre a
madonna si è chiusa pure questa apple
basta bella ragazzi spero il video vi
sia piaciuto non ci sono più porte sono
finite sono fini a meno che non si
aprono le porte di sotto ma in pericolo
dopo che correva di più il personaggio
non sono io che mi ricordo male
correva di più grazie agostino gianmarco
gioco e già la prendono insieme c'è
veramente va a rilento simulatore di
porte chiuse rega ti giuro che a mamma
di big sur che vi ammazzo tutti dal
primo allungo apriste caste fottute
porto ti prendo a calci nel deretano
dammi una chiave d'amico e cosa fai
qualcosa essere inutile chiave della
biblioteca chiave della bibbia lo sapevo
io che c'era una chiave lingue giuro
questa biblioteca ma devo mica provare
su ogni porta la chiave mela apre in
automatico si spera mi chiamo qual è la
biblioteca eccola che culo usata chiare
la biblioteca b ciao zio sono fa vj so
se ti ricordi
sono quello che fai video quello che
aveva già portato due volte ogni l'ho
portata alzava tanto nessuno storico tuo
andato.ma c'e il binario 9 e 3 quarti
questi corrono contro i muri ficcano la
testata e spariscono da fare qua ho
trovato l'oggetto chiave della camera da
letto
no no no no ma corri cribbio quanto
lento quanto è lento il mio personaggio
da una 1000 da casey takeshi pezzo di
culo no ragazzo seller non ci credo la
geografia ma la lettera questa tra mille
camere al meglio allora entra con dentro
che dice meno male perché non si apriva
l'armadio che culo che dio ha posto a
posto ma in quello che ero morto un
sacco di volte la prima volta qua che
mandata di purissimo bene la bravo pino
bravo pino sei bravissimo complimenti
takeshi a posto poi quel disgraziato
maledetto ho trovato l'oggetto
fazzoletto riesci a lancetta che esce
sparito proprio
per strada con forza grazie takeshi
posso soffiarmi il naso complimenti sei
stato utilissimo devo devo andare su sì
non lo so lo so cosa mi quasi si posta
questo c'è un po di 23 anni ancora
alcune cose come ricordo permesso io
salgo ogni cinque secondi perché gli
incavi in mano però vabbè ciao io sto
suonare sono io c'è una macchia rossa
fazzoletto no serve per pulire la
macchia scheggia di piatto ha forse devo
selezionarlo prima e poi si no c'è una
macchia rossa sul pianoforte va bene ma
poi è a cena un numero da mettere ok che
ne sono io ok questo non me lo ricordo
raga sincero immagino che io debba
suonare delle cose no però non so cosa
suonare quale usciamo intanto grazie da
geisha porta aperta a era come ok ok qui
crisi da questa va beh
la porta è chiusa beh ma come facile
sapere il codice della stanza a loro
nome lo dice mi deve uscire un mostro
deve mangiarmi la faccia per eccellenza
ecco questa sia aperta prima non era
persa porto è chiusa ai e la morte che
ti così lontana via via via velocissimo
non me lo ricordavo mai takeshi takeshi
essere in utile con le mont ioni no
sbagliato fatto una cagata lega ma
perché non corri pochi problemi che
affliggono ma con rima crema del norm di
giuro non corre pino il personaggio un
po lentino e anzi valentino e direbbe un
complimento ma porca vacca morta ciao
falliti sto seguendo l'australia alle 8
del mattino di martedì per giunta può
grazie martina non ho capito sta roba
allora è vero perché oggi lunedì non è
domenica sono ancora convinto sia
domenica live view
niente sono morto cosa devo fare io ho
sbagliato mi son dimenticato allora
domanda risotto ok mi chiamano
l'aspettavo speroni salvare che può
anche quindi cosa doveva non ci vado
proprio vado valori qua parte qua c'è
una porta ma questo non sembra fosse in
questa tappezzeria c'è una porta a forse
dovevo fare questo mammamia vuota player
non c'è una maniglia è pia la testata
per cui non posso aprire la porta va beh
ciao barbara
farei mai della stoffa no perché l'ho
già giocato però vabbè saluto tua zia si
chiama gianna che all'ospedale mi
dispiace che stavo spetta anche mia zia
si chiama gianna speriamo non sia la
stessa sto punto chokri bat
grazie per esserci anche oggi il bacino
ciao locci emanuele tommaso thank you
for action devo farmi seguire per forza
quindi immagino è però come faccio a
sfuggirgli il suo zio il funzione il
cesto nel cesso e l'acqua eccesso
scaricati non ci passa diet data era
enorme non ci poteva passare da lì ma
come ha fatto a passarci gigante sto
tizio porco demonio morto dai raga come
si fa sta parte porca vacca era morta
devo andare
c'è una porta aperta l'ho visto questa
bella ai 30 catina vasca da bagno con
demonio aperto un coperto un programma
perché noi siamo ok e non riescono lo
scarso non so se si è capito allora come
come siccome fuori fatti una vita per no
cadono il dukla buco team interessa vai
vai vai vai vai
[Musica]
se continuare ma che minchia stavo mi
stavo già pianto ma le basta
ma il gioco è bello quando sei snello
quindi tu non sei bello andiamo giù che
non ha senso
ciao santiago e addio non ho visto che
chi mi ha chiesto non ho pensato ok
niente ma che cosa devo fare qua nella
cosa ho preso io qualcuno mi aiuti cosa
devo fare
mi fosse entrare dove dove c'era lui
prima immagino quindi posso entrare qua
adesso giusto no ho trovato l'oggetto
accendino guido fuoco questa benzina e
mi do fuoco
comunque quando devo usare dalle cose
che con il verso del piatto sono un po
scomodi comunisti e dai fuoco alla porta
dei quattro ball che non si vuole
accendere la porta ma si diceva stanno
scherzando
questa provata da fuoco la porta sul
serio vabbè grazie alla donazione dai
non so no non cup non sono capace ma
dall'altra parte non ho capito allora
fazzoletto accendino cosa ci fai con un
accendino dopo quel fazzoletto così
perché mi va che sono un piromane non si
vuole a el accendino che non si vuole
accendere a io pensavo non si può essere
centra la porta
allora andiamo a
la porta l'acqua andiamo in cucina più
al gas metano cennina giusto no non è
non è no non è proprio così
però va beh signori non so che non
capisco vai in bagno e prendi il sapone
cell e sapone in bagno ma dove la star
di questo è scemo ma non è vero non mi
date consigli cacciavite ass
ma sì questa una vasca da bagno che cosa
ci fa un cacciavite a stella vasca da
bagno per grattarti la schiena quando di
fare la doccia ma sei scemo ma che ciao
mamma non volesse sorpassi trovato
sapone lascerete ragione bravi c'è un
sapone grazie allora non siete
completamente inutili nei consigli dal
cag e già che ci sei
quindi quale ho preso sapone un
cacciavite a stella ora cosa faccio
pulisco e cacciavite col sapone e gli do
fuoco
ciao jessica grazie mille per la
donazione allora sapone versi sapone sul
fazzoletto si allora di che dopo il
cacciavite e ricoperto di sapone e
magari mettiamo a voi non lo vedete
proprio perché c'è la mia immagine però
è scritto senza cento i verbi
quindi cosa fa pulisco il piano pulisco
altre torte pulisci pulisci ho pulito
bravo bravo fai la colf 915 cazzo di
nove non c'era la calata si terra non
devo morire perché non mi ricordo mai
quando salvato il duo morire sì su buon
dio mi sono non me l'aspettavo mai però
c'è il quarto tempo
mamma mia quanto questo mi basta
by 0 zio michè ha smesso meno male
perché non avevo salutato la particola
dovrei fare tutto mammamia lega
bene bene non me lo ricordo non me lo
ricordavo li hanno messi proprio in
punti dove non te li aspetti mai la
bocca e andiamo avanti
anche kakà quindi cos'è che era 09 15 9
epson quattro numeri però 09 15
9150 tua sorella morta niente zero
9 non è giusto non funzionano ma non c'è
non è quello non era per quella veniamo
sopra questa porta a vedi che c'era st
porta grazie manuela adoro honey anch'io
quando scopro gli enigmi ma takeshi
visto che le porte sono tutte chiuse non
può andare nessuna parte dove è finito
dov'è finito takeshi serie perché da
guro sono tutti i nomi dei suscita che è
takuro pino stai bene ce l'ho visto bene
sì credo di sì però takeshi è sparito ho
trovato un accendino e non c'è un codice
strano sul piano fuori però vabbè poteva
andar meglio la giornata sì credo di sì
pino salire solo quello va beh hai visto
anche tu quel mostro ma gli italici o
quello grosso viola si da non credere
che una creatura del genere esista dopo
che stava per fare battute su pietro pro
navach a tutte le uscite sono bloccate
siamo intrappolati qui migliaia einstein
pare di sì dividiamoci diamo un'occhiata
in giro
esattamente quello che c'è da fare negli
horror dividersi complimenti controllerò
il piano terra lo controllato sei volte
mentre scappavo dal demonio mentre
cercavo saponi quindi non controllare
non serve a niente ho già visto io buona
fortuna va beh
ok buona fortuna guarda signore che se
guardate il segnatempo guarda sito
vecchio video e di dispensa consigli
spacciandomi per un figo vale
no io dovrei ricordarmi quello che ho
fatto non mi accorgo che c'è anche una
porta con quello andato al piano di
sotto non lo vedrò mai più
però bomba beh è andato a controllare
che cosa con la faccia di uno che deve
essere preso per il culo
no perché ci stiamo capendo scusami un
attimo qual è il problema
cosa state prese attente la maniglia
alla maniglia la maniglia che morisse te
possino ho trovato l'oggetto maniglia
della porta est a porta comunque è
veramente utile siete proprio degli
architetti ingegneri e clementi stato
notato e mi stanno crescendo i baffi si
scusatemi e non potevo farmi la barbona
che ciò il cerotto
intanto si sta riducendo quindi tra un
po sparirà si prega di dio
c'è un po di buffy e oggi strano è
l'asse ipo per donazione o gesù
allora facciamo le cose fatte bene dove
andare
intanto l'altro è sparito la vaniglia
stacco per farmi salvare un sistema che
che satana
dall'altra parte io ora qualche arrivo è
che c'è un asset incredibile arrivo
a gesù
siamo andate in secondo
va bene
maniglia qualcuno mi deve spiegare
quella porta che perché spiegatemelo
proprio va bene la showgirl a posto
ma come non si accende dai mi chiama
usano le cose porca la cosa li trovi ce
la vedo niente non vedo a non qualcosa
feto di minimo tipo c'è un letto
non so se lo vedete anche voi io lo vedo
più o meno si vede dell'europa ma non
capisco
usciamo niente mi serve devo accendere
l'accendino ma non ho capito come si
accenderà accendino questo accendo al
cimino non ho capito mi servirebbe della
roba per accettare l'accendino qualcuno
dice che mi serve tipo il gas non lo so
adesso sta là dove stancu cina di
ritrovare il combustibile
grazie amici gr grazie grazie amici 7
gentilissimi senza di voi non so che
farei 915 spero che nella cassaforte ci
sia il combustibile a sto punto sono non
capito quale dovrebbe essere la password
come mi dia una mano aiuto quale la
password del pianoforte di mortacci del
pianoforte
allora non fosse un enigma tipo devo
contare i tasti allora 915 quale come
perché sta lì dove risolvere sto
fottutissimo enigma non ho idea di quale
sia allora 9 15
raga aiutatemi vi prego così cos'è sta
roba datemi un il combustibile nel culo
di takeshi ci avete ragione come si vede
in cucina no ci ho già provato non c'è
cos'è questo devo fare qua può contare i
tasti 123 non lo so 915 manca un numero
scorcio di piatto tana tua madre e
cazzola lesbica no ai ragazzi siamo seri
vero è domandato dove stiamo uscendo da
dove è sceso da dove dato dal buco di
sopra è uscito cioè gigante gigante ma
passa comunque un po come marko marin
non ragazzo male cioè non ha senso giuro
9 al contrario quindi 5 no sì 5 no 5 con
35 16 può esser 516 al contrario 516
06 15 dove giorgio ci conosce vuol dire
non è manca al contrario riga non
funziona 09 15 già provato regala non va
al mario dove uscito non lo so
i numeri va in cassaforte sono i numeri
nella nona capo voce a scritta o non ho
capito è comunque ma e ci sono i simboli
sulla anomica capito che quelli erano
simboli sono simboli sulla cassaforte
l'aspetta sono tasti sono tasti
quell'isola sulla cassaforte sono tasti
quindi ci sono c'è un tasto che è fatta
p questo qua il primo poi c'è il tasto
lungo
lucas oro da 99 a parte il fatto che non
me lo ricorderò mai però vabbè diciamo
di no
il buon vecchio gip che torna utile
ok
dall ometto orco demonio
allora dopo questi questi suoi tasti
questi ok quindi siti che devo pensavo
allora uno no allora il primo numero
gesù cristo il primo numero è una p
capovolta a il primo numero è una e un
66 66 uno stronzo 6 no 615
615 qualcosa giusto
[Musica]
55 europea presenta tv alla 9 16
ok
non si può che portare i tentativi
allora facciamo 619 che facciamo
facciamo tentativi 6 1 si no c59 di un
59 61 56 contrario no 91 61 o dio 9519
non lo so
dovevano 56 ci ha provato a 156 cee no
non ci ha provato il musico dico non va
615 sci che stia provando tutti le ha
provate anche voi in chat o tombola
tombola 9156 159 la ditemelo vedremo
quanto è difficilissimo non lo capisce
nessuno
il primo che rovini il mio canale il
primo che c'azzecca il mio canale cia ve
lo do 61 55 dai creiamo tanto poi li
numeri prima o poi qualcuno uscirà 69 15
si 915 chi offre di più
5 19 9 15 19 15
il cazzo regalo un cult tutti insieme
non facciamo una mente chi me l'ha
indovina ha vinto tutto circa 156 ci ha
provato prima
51 55 69
è la mia seconda risposta cioè dopo dopo
quella era la mia seconda era proprio
quella la mia risposta se non avessi
azzeccato era quella la mia risposta
quindi grazie ma ci sarei arrivato anche
da sola vabbè grazie amici super gentili
io con i ragionamenti ci faccia caso
comunque era non mi ricordo manco più
cos'era ma va bene sono stato bravissimo
sono stato bravissimo
ho trovato l'oggetto chiave della camera
le chiavi della camera da letto del
bambino che bambino c'è mancata che esci
nella camera di takeshi lariano no non
ho capito niente di quello che ho fatto
ma oggi salviamo ci manca solo che muoia
e doveri farmelo non mi ricordo mango
chiamerà camera da letto per culo ciao
zia
come hai fatto entrare che c'era la
chiave domanda proprio così e chi no ma
qualcuno ci riesce a salutarmi in modo
normale non stai bene ha fatto entrare
il cellulare la chiave brighi m lo to
codice dove sono gli altri non ne ho
idea ci siamo preparati non vedete come
si chiama la tipa ma lo dico io si
chiama mica ciao remi mi manchi un sacco
per questo netto passi in fretta un
bacino grazie alla bit l'iva pino ciao
marling grazie mille dall'ansia
ma davvero a vieni con me a spettacoli
come stai scherzando non andrò in giro
per questa villa con quel mostro da
fuori e allora muori nori male ok è
bellissimo me ne frega un cazzo aveva ok
va bene va bene
questi uomini a che cosa possono posta
che spinga a me non frega niente se
siamo o vieni trovato l'oggetto combusti
o ovviamente dove il combustibile
dell'accendino e ovviamente sull'armadio
dove poteva mai essere il combustibile
va bene come si vuole accendino
non è piacevole combustibile sicura
toghe lo più da guru lavoro tieni duro e
puro non mi chiamo tra loro comunque
takuro e quell'altro che è andato al
piano di sotto a controllare ma non so
dove sia finito intanto con cui andiamo
nella stanza buia
ciao like mito
voglio essere un laico l'ho messo il
combustibile non mi ricordo più o a c'è
una candela vai
certo questa non è la candela un
lampadario sarò vabbè c'è una
a cosa lì beh utile sostanza mi dicono
ok totale ne spectre ho trovato
l'oggetto chiave deputati e stai calmo
ma calma ti stai calmo come va
calmissimo devi stare minchiata arriva
un ceffone che te giro la destra non
arriva perché sei alto tre metri però
vabbè non mi chiameranno vero salvato
così scemo questo è scemo o devi stare
fair devi stare fermo come si fa sta
parte corso fortissimo ma questo è scemo
figlia quanto è grosso tra fa passare
come fa passare ovunque che alto sei
metri come come entri nei posti come
faccia possa parte qua stato oggetto
chiara cantina ho capito non era alla
porta chiudila e non mi fa muovere non
mi fa molto prima ti do prima deficiente
anche io non me lo ricordavo ti pare non
si era parlato
lo vedi questo è che bel ciapet che
c'hai allora è a posto
ti giuro che mi sto veramente cagando
addosso e non vorrei dirtelo ma è
proprio così da oscar pack haga sotto lo
scafo si chiama pro la porta mi ammazza
però baba beh poi non è neanche sveglio
che c'è una bambola pro in teoria
dovrebbe saltarmi addosso ma non lo fa
grazie procioni roberta gt life mito e
big jim gradazione ok va bene non mi
ricordo se c'era ancora non scommetto
quello che vuoi che adesso si torna
dalla zia cosa è servita sta roba che
non vivono più a chiave della cantina ok
la chiave la cantina so dov'è questa
cantina io adesso ho usato la chiave la
cantina quella era la voce di mika ma no
mica non canta così male per carità
devo salvare devo correre l'amica no ha
voluto stare da sola cazzi suoi
entra nella cantina ed entra nella
cantina perché devo andare dall equipe e
che non ascoltano è mancata avesse data
gesù
e stata ancora mettendo i codici dalla
cassaforte regalo che usate internet
explorer o ti pare che in quella di io
non vorrei entrare qua dentro per il
semplice motivo che lei non se lo merita
di essere salvata non solo verità
correre veloce come il vento come naruto
quando corre velocissimo co demonio non
riguardano la casa la dalla della gabbia
perfetto allora dobbiamo dare dati tanto
fa così cos'è cos'è sta scena cos'è
facciamo un'altra bella e bel culo però
facciamo un'altra volta ti va
mi piace giocare a gabbia ti da solo
ciao the sea ray grassi mila della
nazione grazie dal chimico puoi dire che
sei panzone panzone tipo ciao mi sa che
hai sbagliato youtuber zio sono
abbastanza magro york e snello
comunque l'importante che il tipo
continui a correre verso di me tanto i
mini in gabbia da solo è bello metterlo
di autopunirsi e mettersi in gabbia
spiegatemi con un quoziente intellettivo
allucinante sto titola te lo meriti
te lo meriti inutile che dentro mercedes
non ti ammazzava lo ammazzavo io quindi
va benissimo così posto zia
e morta e va bene ti punisco cosa devo
fare del fuoco sono fuoco ti scheggio
nei capelli
ti infila cacciavite non facciamo questa
cosa che non è family friendly andiamo
via andiamo via
mi dispiace che se la sia mangiata o
quello che però io gliel'ho detto vieni
con me no stai lì c'erano capito oppure
durerà io ho visto un sacco di oro nella
mia vita so che sarebbe sapevo sarebbe
finita così quindi inutile che mi fa la
predica dopo che devo fà c'è qualcosa di
su e colori o trovato oggetto punta
piatta
cosa vuol dire punta piatta cacciavite
ma lo fa ok non ricordavano perché ho
visto compreso prima che luccica acqua
quello che porta mi sto portando una
sedia ovunque solleva la sera non ha
capito un secolo ha trovato l'oggetto
chiave della cella della cantina della
morte che è al mercato mio padre comprò
chiave della cella della cantina fammi
salvare così scende o chiave della cella
della cantina cella della cantina si su
cristo totali unexpected
no dai non mi ha preso non mi ha preso
da high road c'era corrimano ma va a
cagare
dai non me lo aspettavo ma che cazzo sa
già che quando mangia si trasformano i
personaggi che permetta può far
liberissimo perché già dei capelli che
non sono suoi
cos'è è orribile cela sembra povia
[Musica]
vabbè io anzi c'è i capelli liscissimi
usa pantene dov'è andato a finire va beh
chi se ne frega realtà
ciao lake mito ti voglio sostenere non
c'è non ti preoccupare grazie mi devi
per forza più anzi sai tranquillo io
continuerò a fare video fino alla fine
della mia morte nell'universo integro
cupa tanto youtube sta risolvendo i
problemi sono io che ti risolve i miei
con questa gente tanto giocato 34 minuti
ok io mi sto impegnando non capirlo
chiave della cella alla cantina
beh è la sostanza simpatica e al cimino
eccola questa la cella della cantina
usate la chiave della chiamata cantina
stavolta subito perfetto buono così c'è
una cantina
c'è una candela la voce acquista me la
ricordo
quest'anno ricordo c'è un nome un po
strano ma se guardato dal le sbarre
poi c'è un bambino morto però un altro
disco c 5 3 7 6 5 3 7 6 5 che è un
codice di qualcosa mi ricordo già più
cos'era 5 3 7 6 5 7 6 5 3 7 6 5 3 7 6 la
porta chiusa 5376 non c'entra niente
dargli fuoco
ho capito cosa mi serve sto codice per
poi pensare quello che dove che c'è
un'altra cassaforte
non lo so cosa cosa che sorpreso allora
chi a casillas e la punta piatta
scheggia il mio piatto a cellino ok no
devo andare di qua per forza no perché
non c'è niente dovadola possa aprire
5376 dove lo metto stop oggi mano in
filo c'è qualcosa voglio non ho visto
che 3 7 6
no non ricorderò mai mai mi ricorderò il
codice non servirà mai prodigo già
ok bravi fatto imita promemoria poi se
non so non ricordo ve lo chiedo
tenetelo a mente che poi ve lo chiedo io
non lo mettono nella lavatrice per farla
partire 5376 o iron a torkham cucina sta
il branco ucina devi stare cina mi la
frittata fai fai altre robe nella tua
vita non mi rompere le palle
che palle 5376 dovere cosa sblocca mi
spiega cosa devo fare qua vi prego
cantina devo fare qualcosa quasi sopra
non mi dicono cosa aiuto aiutatemi non
so a in cucina però il tipo era in
cucina quindicina ci sarà qualcosa si
sarà sbloccato qualcosa sicuro so cosa
dobbiamo vedere no si è sbloccato un gas
cioè il tipo era in cucina a caso forse
era il microonde ricordarmi sentono come
promemoria 53 70
non so cosa serve la lega che devo fare
che vuoi va dimmelo
non lo so regalo non so cosa devo aiuto
fatemi girare alle 53 66 53 76
se c'è una porta nascosta qualcosa sotto
il tappeto
non lo metto sto codice che dopo fa nel
pianoforte dietro a libreria la libreria
in fondo la cantina la libreria in fondo
alla cantina questa questa qua questa
questa in fondo
grazie amici
se no non me lo sarei mai ricordato no a
si sposta pure l'altro che a devo xvi
carlos vita scritta vita non riesco a
girare la vita con questo cacciavite
minchia aziende pur dal ferramenta ma a
noi la punta la punta piatto che occhio
che cambia puntale piacevole si ok
mammamia what a ferramenta un'altra
cassaforte ok e 537 è giusto ma ricordo
più bello
signori del professor layton qua altri
che fa vigilia ho trovato l'oggetto
chiave dell'edificio annesso sì ma parla
italiano per cortesia
ho fatto entrare lì ma [ __ ]
veramente male ma ho fatte na tisana ci
sto male
siamo seri o vabbè solo a me sembra cane
chi sia vero sembra cane quito cure
iniziamo mangiarla gente di cure il tipo
con cui lo bello nella gabbia è vero
allora perché la gabbia si può chiedere
solo da dentro quindi mi chiuderei con
lui sarei un po deficiente per ora una
bella idea
c'è una pedina se se non so come
coniugare i verbi però avete capito come
salva voli che per l'amore di gesù
cristo che è o chi faccio solare dalle
scale e dorigo usata la chiave
dell'edificio ne sta bene sarà meglio ho
finalmente un edificio allegro a mamma
mia rega
siamo a un'ora di live siamo
all'edificio ha messo bene questa segna
più o meno la metà del gioco non lo so
devi fare un di pausa successe se siete
d'accordo ok vi lascio con rumore della
pioggia di minuti di pausa e arriva così
vado a pisciare a bere e toni
lei o pisciato spero che il rumore della
pioggia via via conciliato suonato dai
con la mia ragazza perché ci fai morire
dal ridere grazie fi cioè scommesso che
con questa donazione di arrivare a 60
mila ne mancano 5 mila ci siamo stasera
melata spero mi chiedevano a cannes
ciconìa su importanti quindi secondo me
tracy un bozzetto però siamo con te
amico mio
let's be friends che allora edificio
annesso che bello rumore della pioggia
vero ma non iniziamo male perché vi
faccio db borri pesto il culo ve lo dico
già ce l'ho ancora l'argentino che
sembra sia finito minchia l'ha acceso
due volte mag accendino è mai preso dal
cinese si serio mi chiama più volte l'ho
usato non sono scemi sono scemi ma
veramente
ma siamo seri regalo questa roba qua c'è
una mi devo impiccare ho finalmente
gioca fa per me
bella brough salda
che bello un enigma io sì che riesco a
farli enigmi perché sono una persona
molto intelligente non sono capaci dai
facciamo cose serie giochiamo a un
invece di sta roba è
ho trovato l'oggetto bambola vabbè ma
c'è un'altra volta con acqua manca
manca la corda vabbè ma ci sono altre
bambole giusto ma qua questo è stato il
braccio alzato e qua non c'è niente
quindi metti la bambola no
eccola il progetto ma si metti metti lo
metti la metti lo sco però alcune non
hanno gli occhi
raga non mi ricordo niente però rumore
della piaceri la samp è ovviamente
questo padova ha quindi devo prima
finire questo e poi teoria cosa devo
farlo mettere la testa li aspetta che ci
riprovo picchia raga me dovete far fare
gli enigmi che madonna non so fare due
p2
veramente non traina sul serio
gesù cristo ma non si può fare è
impossibile ma neanche se mi impegno 20
volte riesco scusami non ho mai
fattibile
non si può fa storico dove in fila la
bambola ok c'è un accreditato dagli
occhi e ci troviamo poi dopo dai o devo
usare la bambola non ricordavo provoca
la bambola se non me la facciano mi
funziona non vado in giro certo alla
luce dai simpatico sta piovendo michia 6
einstein zio veramente non so come
faremo senza le sue deduzioni fratello
nel mondo ha proprio bisogno di te senti
chi se ne frega no gesù quanto stanzani
mancano questa no scusami che stavo già
parlare volevo di andare quindi sopra
solo che non c'è di prima non ci rimane
nasce un sito la di prima ma non c'era
prima no non c'entravo attaccato al muro
che chi mette i tavoli attaccati al muro
che schifo come fai a servire quelli al
fine del tavolo che ornamenti di di deo
toschi fonterra fatela arredare bene sta
casa minchia alla fine del muro di no
dai a sei serio
usate la chiara ero quando vanno a
maronna mia di carne dai cheppallle
avanti alla bambola meyer lamarte
impiccherei se potessi ma non ci arriva
la sedia e all'anno
ma che non debba spegne la luce dammi
salva
quando è uscito quello prima da adobe
com'è possibile perché c'è anche la
parte destra non si apre bene sta roba
non doveva succedere però è successa via
via via veloce porta aperta veloce ok
perfetto su arrivato ma andata benissimo
cosa è successo
ok è sufficiente so cascato non casca
può succedere per ciò che ha scado ciao
ciao ciao alex grazie dell'anziano
questo abbastanza aprirà mai figura di
gesù in terra ma questa mi ha fatta
persista abbiamo fatto qua non ci sono
ancora stato c'è una luce non mi entrare
satana nella porta lampadina buco che
brutto brutto lampadina nel burro
tornano lampadina non mi ricordo niente
ragazzi sta parte non mi ricordo niente
zero come rileva pre casa 6 capo natale
ma come come è uscito da lì buttati giù
[Musica]
capello fotte lo fa una donna dai campus
strada nella maniglia è perfetto per
calmi state calmi tutto sotto controllo
tutto giusto non ho capito niente ma
tutto giusto minchia che c'è ansia di
vivere nella vita approccio tranquilli
niente perché ho preso lampadina
lampadina trovato la lampadina e
comunque è uscito dal camino tipo babbo
natale consista c'è la lampadina qua non
c'è niente la caffettiera
no niente sotto le sedi e niente né
camino c'è un camino io veramente non so
cosa dire c'è veramente sei proprio una
persona arguta genuino no perché è
finito il combustibile ovviamente grazie
giallo della novazione molto obiettivo
latina nel camino che ne so io che ci
devo fare sta cosa serve questa stanza
nell'universo a farlo far uscire la
gente dai camini chiama stai calmo però
siamo capite a c'è una scatola va bene
cosa serve una scatola foglio stella
cacciavite lampadina cin modino scheggia
no mentre qua no alla scatola va lì
perché così almeno ci arriva ok a
portare nella difficile noi bueno tra un
progetto combustibile a cellino grazie a
dio
ringraziando a cristo ma vedere cosa ci
dice mamma mia che al sesto gioco ogni
volta
eccolo lo trovavo perché c'è l'icona di
un rossetto stato ripreso sta accendino
da da kiko con io non c'era effetto
sonoro mi sono pagato lo stesso addosso
che cosa minchia fai qui cosa fai qui e
lì la prima sei tu pino non spaventa yo
yo spavento ma sei scemo ma il 6 nel
buio
takeshi stai bene sì ma è solo una
questione di tempo prima che venga
catturato dopo il mostro non c'è luogo
dove fuggire ma va se solo io e solo io
non avessi suggerito di venire qui non
saremo in questo caso pure è stato pur
tu a suggerirlo è è tutta colpa mia
bravo no dai
io non posso avere dei deficienti così
come amici però mi rifiuto io mi rifiuto
di credere quindi che c'era e c'è
veramente una cosa ridicola ridicola
questa cosa vuol dire ridicolo a si
muove la strada va bene nemmeno commenti
faccio meglio che cosa serve essere
stato scusami
che sarà stato spingo il giro per casa
si concentra nelle porte entrata ha già
ok in questo mentre la stavo spingendo
mi sono ricordato doron per mentre la
stavo spingendo perfetto quindi quando
non servirà più pietra blu blu la
vedrebbe la pietra filosofale alcune
della bambola inserisce a peter liu
nell'occhio della bambola si sa c'è la
bambola come tempo ma dov'erano le
bambole scusa sono qua ricordo che
metteremo ciao carolina grazie della
donazione commessa giusto no
sono cazzi stavamo l'ho ce l'ho presa ma
come mi spieghi aiuto non mettiamola di
la qual cosa servirà torino dopo giusto
allora non è che sto qui a pettinar le
bambole o funzioni o funzioni non è che
funzioni a metà messo gli occhi
basta devi funziona c'è un'altra statua
comunque io vorrei spingere questa però
non posso spingerla perché è troppo in
fuori capito c'è un cammino ma posso
accedere il cammino adesso però
aspettano di salvare che non so com'è
che scende satana facendo i camini si
bea ha avuto un risvolto positivo nella
mia vita sta cosa fresca o dai dai è
vero non posso uscire non c'è se questo
no mi ha [ __ ]
dopotutto arrivo io cerco uno c'era un
disegno naja la morte ieri a dire questo
dai che scarso nella vita che è scarso
che scarso mamma mia che scarso grazie
alla donazione
mammamia merito che scarso unico potevo
andare dentro l'armadio no l'ho dovuto
aspettare un idiota che esci quando ci
hai voglia a noi cercando un po capito
cosa dovevo fare perché mentre stava
volo visto il camino ha riscaldato il
foglio che mi fa vedere 290 scritto con
la mia calligrafia dicono andavo alle
elementari
vabbè due mezzi un po 290 vale parisi
non uscire incazzo brucia la banda
labbra del consiglio funziona o funziona
ho trovato l'oggetto pietra rossa ho
trovato l'oggetto pietra blu ma dai
quindi non dovevo dovevo bruciare la
bambola arriva dai zio fa il serio
si possono anche squadre di una statua
l'ho fatto perché io nella vita sono
sfortunato perché no ricevuto volo costi
giochi faccio schifo perché sono entrato
nell'ultimo unica stanza in cui non dove
entra
290 ricordate me lo stato per fare
brucia la bambola giusto ma non a lla a
me mi di 8 ragazzi usate sono capace
vanno la rugiada salvavamo prendi a
bambola e ne titolo sa petrolo penso che
debba mettere le pietre dentro è dentro
pietro dentro la bambola che non ci ha
gli occhi questa no questa ciglia che
faceva era dall'altra parte 50 per cento
già sbagliato
che strana coincidenza
ecco grossa ei blu navy è perché ho
trovato l'oggetto testa della barba o
che la metto dove c'era il puzzle prima
giusto non uscire grazie a dio
finalmente la vita mi regala delle gioie
finalmente una gioia a testa della
bambola perfetto o bastasse casseforti
kakà to gaza 29 01 ricordare e sgrò my
friends stato l'oggetto chiave della
cantina le chiavi della panchina le
chiavi della camera la parola annuncia
porta volta spetta morto non c'è morto
cioè fatto non c'è cortesia morto caduto
portò a impiccarsi prima e takeshi mi
evitavano infarto in team
bravo bravo stylist e madalina mano
torino è morto
se questo se inutile se questo sei mio
amico non lo sento
cioè non lo vedi neanche da vicolo
makers thomas ikimi amico perché sei
morto no macché ragioni bravo quello che
è successo ma che pure morto vuol dire
che devi stare fermo due bubble ucciso
cioè non va beh
il nostro prende le sembianze dei miei
compagni deve prendere le sembianze dei
compagni inutili giusto veloce
e ci vai via fuori nell'universo
mi devi seguire pertanto che succede in
caso di no perfetto
cosa devo farlo sorpreso a chiave da
cantina quindi ho aperto la cantina che
immagino sia l'ultima porta che manca ad
aprire quella sono io sono una persona
paziente però non per cioè paziente fino
a un certo punto se i miei compagni mi
cagano gas grazie anche a dov'è la
cantina di qua mi ricordavo scusa troppe
porte indagato non uscire da nessuna
parte
per cortesia bene usate la chiave della
cantina sto curando la rai per
rilassarmi di alla tesi che sto
scrivendo per laurearmi al marzo
speriamo mitico favi spero di
incontrarti avanti così grazie sarà un
bacino bocca al lupo per la tua tesi
seguo i miei miei video dopo la tesi
perché potrei danneggiarti un po il
quoziente intellettivo però non lo
sapete già quindi sapete a cosa andate
incontro grazie max paiella donazioni
tra chi allagati sace darth vader qua
dentro lampadina widmann
semmai mi venga un idea mamma mia come
sono simpatico come me li merito sti 4
milioni ha tra l'altro se volete 4,9
milioni di iscritti ho scoperto
stamattina
così sono arrivati altro ieri però ovvio
ciò internet explorer nel computer
quindi grazie il bobby fare un video
hoffer non ci soffermiamo adesso che
sono tra l'altro pino è uno studente
delle scuole medie c'è scritto qua non
avevo letto
studente delle scuole medie ora si
spiegano tante cose tra cui il fatto che
la matematica non è il tuo forte perché
non era neanche il mio arrivo avevo 5
matematica alle medie le medie dove ti
sei te lo tirano in faccia a travo 5 è
una roba di cui vantarsi per niente poi
ci accadeva e almeno almeno 6 cioè non
perché ci stiamo perché cosa ci credo
perché tiro questi discorsi non
interessa un cazzo nessuno gli avanti
accennata raccomando non studiate non
gioca dei giochi del di merda come
faccio io
cioè io gli ho cliccato su una roba a
caso si è spostata vabbè c'è che genio
sono che c'è chi sono che genio come
faccio esseri intelligenti non si apre
figure questa roba
si vabbè che mai preso per tom cruise in
mission impossible ma c'è una candela va
centro dopo l'ultima così continuiamo al
buio
vabbè ciò fa vivo il tuo zaino ne vado
fiero ciao dei magic world of the lol
grazie per chiamarti così che mi è
facile dirti il nome
spero che ti piaccia perché ci ho messo
un sacco a fare il design altro che è
chiara ferrari parte l'anno prossimo
ancora più figo però chi se ne frega di
quello comunque sono contento di me
piace anche prossima volta faccio un 7
di vasche da bagno fa vigili a cena
dell'acqua dentro era acqua lercia
quella va bene cosa devo fare io qua
mentre non vedente già perché poi sto
giocando la voglio vedere a tutto
schermo no però in realtà io ho
allargato lo schermo per farvi vedere lo
schermo è piccolissimo quindi per
guardare devo fare così cioè veramente
se avessi un decimo in meno non vedrai
che cosa sto facendo
sì ha ringraziato gesù cristo
salvo dei decimi ciò continua balli lo
farò
no forse no che culo ha trovato libro
illustrato
sempre in si giochi la ga consiglio si è
giocato st robe a ste robe rpg sempre
controllare tutto qualsiasi cosa pure il
buco del culo di mons così ho trovato
libro illustrato che bello questo libro
proprio ben bel libro è sì
per un segnalibro quello stato oggetto
segnalibro così storico per scusami non
ho capito ha proprio il libro l'ho
buttato non c'è più il libro non c'è più
però il segnalibro va bene di cosa si va
indietro che milioni pubblico fatto da
sempre sta roba scusami parte qua c'è
una porta chiusa quindi senza vita punto
piatto tutti segnali tra gli stessi cori
della porta quindi immagino sia da fare
qualcosa la porta nel mio cervello
mentre cerco di capire le cose ci sono
due criceti che pedalano fortissimo
cosa vuoi dalla mia vita di sicuro ti
ricordi di me sono chiara quella ragazza
di te abbracciato per un bel po meglio
in internet a roma dipende o il tuo
numero di telefono e promesso non don
giovanni ciao chiara grazie alla
donazione print princess all art ariel
l'incrocio tra altair e ariel ciao
chiara secondo tantissimo tempo e ti
adoro grazie mille anch'io
anche il mostro mi segue da tantissimo
tempo e mi adora mi ha già seguito un
sacco yacht e non capisco cosa devo fare
sono stupido brucia cosa se il
segnalibro ai colori rosso verde bianco
blu ok ho capito
due blue un rosso 2 bianchi 2 verdi
quindi due sono rosso e uno quindi 1222
credo no volevo fare gli intelligenti
allora equa la soluzione deve solo
capirla celo celo dovrà solo solo
capirla
allora nulla dalle due pezzi verdi due
pezzi blu due pezzi bianchi un pezzo
rosso e giusto quindi il percorso è uno
pezzi bianchi sono due
ritornando al discorso dalla matematica
scusatemi che faceva la tesi prima mi
scusi ma ho bisogno di una persona un po
intelligente per fare una cosa che io
non sono capace
immaginatevi ceri i criceti nile giro no
non sto capendo no no no no non capisco
sono stupito nella vasca e cazzo stai di
qua che c'era l'ascolta
ma se non ora che ne so io ma che ne so
io ma che ne so ma io non sono capaci
mica faccio lo gli ultimi bari
faccio la colf porco demonio scusa per
questo la porta e quali no in chiave
rosso no è una chiave fini è finta la
chiave finta e finta che a me serve una
chiave rosso c'era non serve a niente
però l'ho trovata ma non sembra niente
nella vasca cioè quando l'ho usata l'ho
usata
cosa faccio non funzionano non basta
dovevo xvi
vabbè dovevo svitare il coso ac
inserisco disegnano mano sicura the man
of the il rosso è sempre uno comunque
rosso ci aveva azzeccato
allora e criceti ni possono prendere una
pausa rosso uno blu 147 blu 7 rosso uno
blu 7 bianco 3 verde 2 rosso 1
verde 2 bianco 3 blu 7 12 37 grazie
grazie a tutti grazie a tutti grazie di
credere in me sempre ogni giorno
iscrivetevi al canale attivate la
campanella che gli fa arrivare le pile e
[ __ ] a breve i one direction
signori questo è un gioco che fa per me
sono una persona molto organizzata di
fronte a codesto ingegno scappano tutti
e chi libia lamachi libia genoa questi
ragazzi di oggi kg biasima sia quel
tappeto è mosso e l'ho visto a non mi
fotte the disco a gennaio trovato il
disco di gigi d'alessio stava sotto il
tappeto perché c'è darth vader che di
continuo mi entra nelle cuffie non solo
sentite che fastidio salute per il lutto
scusatemi io mangio tardi quindi vivo
questa stanza non so cosa c'è dentro ma
quell'armadio non mi fido grazie al mito
della donazione non mi fido non mi fido
non mi fido
da culo pino come fate entrare come hai
fatto a fare il segnalibro la statua la
bambola e al piano terra come hai fatto
ad arrivare fino a qua poi se per un po
brutto per un altro discorso
io faccio un po più schivo ancora quindi
paguro stai bene
sì ma mi sono storto la caviglia
aspettano qui per un attico e la
caviglia takuro aspetta che sicuro
[Musica]
meli merito si stretto ok provato questo
poco fa portalo con te non mi dare cose
che poi ti devo infilare nel sai tu dove
trovato l'oggetto aceto tra tutte le
cose una pistola una chiave un tua madre
all'aceto laccetto che cosa ci faccio
con lacci devo condire l'insalata russa
cosa ci devo fare con l'aceto cosa ci
devo fare con la cosa devo farci con
l'aceto cosa devo fare con la spiega lo
spiega mi cosa ci devo disinfettare la
lavastoviglie cosa vuoi di preso
veramente una colf cosa cosa io le ho
ricavato da tutto questo ricavato
dell'aceto cioè non so se io non ho
parole dell'angolo duro solo fare dicono
più dovevo andare adesso voices talmente
tante stanza che non so più domanda
allora c'è qualche stanza che non si
apre quindi io posso dare il mio aceto
però a questa porte chiuse ma accetto
posso usarlo immergi la chiave la chiave
rossa nell'aceto io volevo buttarlo
sulla porta però vabbè se la ruggine si
è tolta dalla chiave beh certo era
quello che immaginavo era proprio quello
che volevo fare chiave del cancello
ferrato immagino non sia questo lo
scortano cielo ferrato è quello di
mordor grazie definito dalla donazione
molto gen tre agenti cos'è che non ho
parlato
paguro no vabbè non lasciamo stare
quello più stalli e meglio cosa è il
cancello ferrato va bene non ho idea di
dove sia di perché esista ma c'è un
cancello ferma trova nella parte
evidentemente da mo no no no non la temo
rissa e cugino demonio morto
marta
perché sai cos'è che cosa ho fatto qua
chiave del cancello ok mi fa incavolare
per cortesia dove devo andare
lovato quello del mostriciattolo ma che
sta di cos'è sto cancello ferrato c'è
qualcosa devo tornare indietro sicuro
anzi da curò la smetto dai che magari è
meglio ha mai aperto sono un cazzo ha
aperto già è aperto o chiuso aperto
vabbè vabbè è aperto il cancello teoria
se mi segue un tizio per qualche strano
motivo lo ri capitoli dentro ve lo giuro
su dio ti prego seguitemi
seguitemi vi supplico voglio che mi esca
fuori qualcuno perché lo voglio
rinchiudere nel cancello futuro vi prego
fatemi uscire un mostro qualcosa come
prima di subito dai sarebbe ha tra
l'altro l'albania non la posso mettere
qua allora lampadina l'ho presa qua che
scendono dai un mostriciattolo a caso vi
prego la vasca da bagno con vasca va mai
essere scemi c'entra la vasca da bagno
scusami
questa vasca da bagno questa qua ci
avete ragione ci avete ragione prodotto
spingerla di sotto e non come come
dovrei come dovevo saperla sta roba sono
ma dicevate voi la chiave per chiudere
il cancello non si apre lo stesso grazie
dei magi grazie solfi e giulio o andrea
che sofia dei due
giulio andreani kong scusami avevano
ricordato sul tuo nome verso il tuo
nickname
perché se una persona che ci tiene agli
amici finito l'acqua usata la camera
questo puoi smettere di aiutarmi nelle
orecchie ti ringrazio c'è un bottone
sotto al dipinto premi il bottone eh beh
non è uscito satana siamo vittoriosi i
premi tutto premi tutto di cos'è sta
roba cos'è cos'è cosa devo fare qua c'è
un ordine preciso che non conosco 123
no sarà uno due tre di sicuro non è il
primo il rock dell'ultimo ragazzino saw
ii iii li ho provati tutte le
combinazioni
no non lo so raga aiuto che sta roba
non ho sentito gli oggetti c'è qualcosa
disco disco a vedi a devo seguire è un
disco a quello di gigi d'alessio aveva
allora rosso giallo giallo blu giallo e
vabbè rosso giallo giallo blu giallo
rosso rosso dice rosso giallo giallo
giallo rosso nero quota player barra
metallica della infine i testicoli cosa
che fai
gli prende a mazzate gioielli cosa che
devi fare questa sbarra metallica
io vi giuro su dio che qualcuno lo
chiudo prima o dopo qualcuno
sbarra metallica cose che serve starò
più duramente
robe cose stanno accadendo chiave della
porta nascosta sacchet e io non ho idea
di come abbia fatto però va bene
l'esito non ho idea di cosa ho fatto
andiamo avanti
ricordatevi che sono riuscite a pirlo
tranquilli leiber rimane online sembra
si posso ce la fa io ho tanto so già che
non ci riesce quindi non dovrei portare
takuro qui no
madonna del è sì è sì un ondata ammazzo
ti ammazzo ti ammazzo te lo giuro che lo
giuro t'ammazzo madonna rega odio la mia
vita odio tutto questo takuro se sei
morto
ti ammazzo e vivo nei loro menù e vieni
dici sul serio pino sì sì sì takuro
seguito a te entrato nel mio corpo sono
proprio contento eccoli studente nelle
scuola me ne mazza or lo ammazzo poi mi
curo il nome meguro esiste in giapponese
comunque quindi tekuro e meguro
giapponese un po tipo il romano grazie
mi stia grazie sofia grazie mattia fanno
rima ma sono le formazioni da culo non
me va spa minchiate fatemi uscire tanto
non esco fatto questo cambiamenti e che
anzi venuta al barbera sì sì tanto lo
sapevo lo sapevo che tanto lo sapevo
via via spero ce muori muori c moric
e molto molto è morto e continua a
seguirvi continua a seguirmi continua a
seguirmi non se ne va non va via
cosa che mi muoverò fatto sorella che lo
annuncerà neanche ma non c'era neanche
cosa che i muove ma dove ma non c'era ma
non c'era nemmeno come game over
vabbè che è entrato dalla porta ma
sterrati milano seconda ci ripensavo
comprendiamo proposta consegnata a loro
favore andiamo nella tua semmai non ci
sente di sotto se cessato la cosa che
volevo fatto all'inizio no l'ho aperta
che [ __ ] l'offerta che idiota l'ho
aperta dai dai
ce l'avevo fatta fare con uno fare l'ho
aperta subito due dudu polo aperto duro
google ha aperto la porta aperta ma che
deficente
che deficente raga ed efficiente avevo
fatto perfetta salva la mente corre no
le libri parigi in giro no no ma perché
io sono stupido perché ma non ce l'ha
promesso in colori co ceo fa ce l'ho
fatta rega idiota ciao benedetta grazie
mille della donazione epicentrale dai
facciamo niente ragazzi come fa passanti
guardate e grosso non ci passano anche
nella porta ormai tra l'istituto buco
come allora la situazione sta diventando
veramente pesante regalo dico quello che
meno topi tutti a schiaffi a due a due
film diventano disparità
ce l'ho fatta la prima volta prima apple
non riesco più casetta guardata basso
era riuscita a farla roba incredibile
[Musica]
l'aperta lui l'aperta lui l'ha aperta
lui l'ha aperta lui stavolta non l'ha
aperta io ah ok quindi non puoi chiudere
non puoi chiudere la gente ed è ok vi
sono molto quattro volte ma non ho
capito che non voglio della tempo non
l'ho aperta io stavo da per te lo giuro
quindi non si possono chiudere nelle
celle vabbè ci sta perché in realtà la
cella la faida dentro ma da fuori no non
so per quale motivo il creator inizio
gioco ha pensato a questa cosa perché
mia figlia perché se la verità dentro la
voi avrebbero fuori però vabbè non puoi
vederli dentro è peccato ragazzi abbiamo
provato sarebbe stato molto più belli
per molto ciao io mila piazze per la
donazione ma sei sicuro che non lo puoi
chiudere dentro come sono simpatico
ragazzotto che non ho parole
perché mi haliti nelle orecchie dei
problemi al cervello ai
arrampicati fa qualcosa non lo so faccio
qualche dato chiave della porta sul
prodotto da far sì che la porta sul
retro quale porta rimasta chiusa tra
tutte quelle che ho visto chi ami porta
sul retro cazzo stai qui indossava
portatore di una scusa la porta sul
retro la stessa porta sul retro che si
porta sul retro la rega spedite
difficile moderno estremamente agibile
dove c'era una bambola dimetterà
lampadina se in scena uno scemo io forse
c'è ragione due però non va a meta la
lampadina funziona benissimo la
lampadina la porta sul retro signori
basta co sta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta di
mettere lampadina come la bambola senza
testo nel cast veramente questa è vero
ci sarei mai arrivato e che minchia
serve scudo
all ombra a qui c'è qualcosa non sembra
post in questa tappezzeria tira la via
minchia ragazze ecco non possono non
avrei mai mai mai mai mai a 0 mai se
sarei mai arrivato sono ammalato che non
ci sarebbe mai arrivato
va bene
cioè se no sarei veramente non è
arrivato
ma io non posso passare in mezzo matto
con cui mi fa piacere che una bella
giornata almeno fuori va bene va bene
andiamo sempre uguale e sempre in un
edificio brutto volo dopo era
bruttissimo questa orribile
c'è una via di mezzo che potete pulire i
muri no
ma dov'è il brutto andata a fuoco tutto
qua ma che è studente nell'armadio
peccato ci speravo di trovare takeshi
che però è morto però che è più utile da
morto così non ce l'ha posto fra l'altro
la cappella speriamo che google non
censuri video perché dico la parola
cappella perché questa è una cappella si
guarda a pregare in questo momento
quello che mi serve c'è un bottone sotto
il banco raimi boccone si è servito
tantissimo
quanti bottoni esistono social banco
scusami ci sono dei bottoni robot o ma
ci sarà una sequenza da premere ma non
so quale sia quindi non premuta una caso
vediamo
ovviamente non diamo via il buco è
troppo buio per vedere in basso a meno
male e troppo pericoloso scendere ma
perché dovresti infilati in un buco
spiegami sopra
ma mi salva bellissimo jackie infarto mi
sono tirato addosso via via via no è
però dai pensieri poi infilarsi nel suo
buio anche di fuori di ciechi che palle
brava si vede bene che brucia solo se è
fuori siete bravi permesso
la pioggia non gli piace dunque siamo il
live d'onore e 45 forse non riesco a
fare milioni
strano farò in un'altra ben porca
[ __ ]
ma poi c'è sempre a cappella quindi non
da riso e non mi fate non mi fate uscire
gente per cortesia perché mi sembra il
caso
c'è un quadro qua posso andare al quadro
senza che satana mi sbocchi dalle
mattonelle grazie c'è un pene no sembra
un po cos'è scheggia nel piatto
fazzoletto accendino
volete quando finisce la live
verso mezzanotte in teoria se lo finisco
la porta è chiusa
ho finalmente cosa ci fa il mio compito
di matematica sul muro
accedi a c'è una porta quella vedo
qualcosa non sembra posto in questa
batteria dai ragazzi dobbiamo esser
entrati in una casa giapponese
abbandonata tagliate i maturi perché c'è
roba di tromba come salva molto
simpatica gente nell'armadio sono tutt
ora mi stupisco più rega no no no no no
non ho fatto in tempo a nascondermi meno
male eh si questo è art attack tenere
comunque come finivo come fini voi e mi
art attack
sapreste dirmi dove ho usato il colore
blu il nostro artista trovato l'oggetto
dado ma perfetto
giochiamo a da jensen dragons in questo
momento che è molto utile occupo a
monopoly
c'è un po chi è rientrato ho trovato un
dato un problema non so cosa mi potrebbe
servire gli altri
un dato a sei facce con diversi puntini
minchia mi serve un labbro in questo
momento scusate se mi sembra forse dove
lanciarlo 18 no sicuramente di facce
come ci sono sei
panchina però non c'entra c'entra
sicuramente con le panchine però non so
in che modo sta provando a capire cosa
che cosa state consigliandolo non
capisco cioè non so cosa devo fare mai
migliosi avevate ragazzi di andare a
domini andate tanto la live rimane
online
vabbè ho un dado non so a cosa forse
posso entrare
hai visto che senza che questa scusa
ok abbiamo capito ora questo c'è un
quadro o dato mancante tiene benissimo
tra serve stava cagato ok ci sono i
banconi allora destra sinistra giù
sinistra sulle se come minchia me lo
ricordo allora aspetta come facciamo
foto col telefono ne fa la foto ok
detta o fatta in questo punto ecco
così mi ricordo bene no
perfetto mi corrono anche più dove la
cappella pensate come sta messo le
scopriamo allora di questo questo primo
premere bottoni si questo è secondo per
mele bottone sì il primo lo aveva
azzeccato comunque in basso a sinistra
in alto a sinistra basso a destra in
alto a destra
let's go my friends doveva essere giusto
noi buono molto buono molto bene come
salva prima di entrare sotto la cappella
non sempre però che brutto astori 6 come
un fratello maggiore ti stimo bacio zio
ha smesso di aiutarmi nelle orecchie c'è
un corridoio bianco is this paradiso c'è
un altro pene per questo sono quadri da
compare con questa porta quando scoprirà
mai figura devo comporre il quadro
sicuro giu
bello salvare nel buio dove non vedi che
cosa ci sia che magari ce l'ha il
demonio davanti a me o no è un'opera o
trovato l'oggetto pezzo blu ma come non
si apre come non si apre ma dai non
posso prendere tre amici vi serve però
penso però va beh vedo niente due celle
sono solo prigioni stracult ci arrivo
tutto chiuso figure la porta è chiusa va
bene va bene siamo su cosa c'è un penta
cos'è le vocazioni di di santana questa
ho trovato l'oggetto corda mici in picco
conoscendo 22 cose posso farlo o la
lancio
attraverso queste sbarre qua no oppure
scendo nel condotto di sotto c'era un
condotto una certa vi ricordate scelto è
quello giustamente diamo nel condotto
tutti insieme appassionatamente che
comunque io non ho capito come si prende
quel cosaro blu e io ti dico
o devo tenere aperta la porta cristo le
volte voi non ci sono più volevo
nascondermi sotto al letto meno male che
non è arrivato
vabbè sopra
c'è un oggetto a nella panchina c'è un
oggetto poi panchina questa è vero che
pirla
ho trovato un oggetto bastone quindi con
questo paci pillole l'oggetto che non
siano chiavi questo è giusto non avevo
visto il bastone corrie ecco un lungo
passo la descrizione dell'oggetto è un
lungo bastone
se mi fossi chiamato rocco invece di
pino non ci ho bisogno di questa roba
chiave dello studio molto bene che
studio che sono nello studio rai non mi
ricordo niente adesso c'è pericolo solo
l'inizio e adesso non mi ricordo niente
studio pensi a questo presentato prima è
tutto aperto
quindi immagino sia su queste cose le
posso prendere dal muro no preparati
all'infarto semplici tradurla stone e
comunque rega grazie mille della
donazione però non mi sono preparato
l'infarto l'ho preso la corda ecco la
salva ama quindi non c'è bisogna andarci
nella cosa ah ah ah ecco come si faceva
ho trovato un oggetto pezzo blu perfetto
allora via
molto bene invece sta la cappella non
tocchiamo più di questo c'è controlli ma
tutte le stanze quasi sicuri c'è niente
in teoria devo andare di sopra giusto a
fare meglio
ok pezzo lui e lo scheggia di piatto
no accendino no cacciavite no vabbè
chiave dello studio è che uno di questi
è per forza usata la chiave dello studio
molto bene o no bello sto dipinto c'è
una bibbia doveva quando ci sono dei
bookies c'è un quadro che è caduto da
solo ma c'era un gatto non l'ho mica
visto va bene però che minchia se sei
brutto pepa pre voto corre no velenoso
male
ciao scatto questo non è che sono stati
già come lo zio dai porca vacca northup
rocca dai sul serio cos'è sta roba
quanto brutto
vabbè non mi avvicinandomi a v non mi
avviciniamo l'italiano corregge caccia
vive adesso svicolato school amico o
svitato qualcosa non so cosa il gatto
scappa io corro come le prodotto corri
corri corri a non c'è più niente
ecco ci ha ospitato il quadro è vabbé
nicchia aiuto
[Musica]
spero che non mi segua perché non sa che
fare minchia che quello grazie eleonora
per la donazione
[Musica]
così la vita
abbiamo finito no dai cos'è sta roba
cos'è ma è una presa per il culo va dai
o basta basta ya basta
siamo taggati gas basta
finiamo no perché per cortesia è pezzo
blu cioè io non ho parole questo gioco
veramente no no no no non ho parole
io non ho veramente duro
facciamo bene
cosa ho preso un pezzo blu pensato
personale ma anche neanche a 1 in teoria
allora ho controllato tutte le porte
tranne no no c'è la cassaforte di sopra
c'è la cassaforte dito hai un bel culo
normale che ti seguono grazie grazie
grazie grazie lido per la donazione
molto obiettivo sorry e dove la casta
ecco non mi ricordavo più un piano tutto
bene non ci arriva alla serie a sedia mi
chiedono ma certo i nostri sono alti due
metri che le palle cassaforti gigantesco
ok no no dài dài no ti prego dai ma che
ne so io dai raga che palle dov'è il
codice
no dai minchia che palle sul serio no
raga che palle veramente pecknold
ditemelo di premi subito dove lo trovo
le tende hanno dei si sa le tende tende
le tende ten nicchia se non sarei andato
lei comunque le tende hanno dei simboli
a me ne ricordo uno che il 5 pentagramma
dai tempi allora 1 partiamo da aa3
045 30 45 sarà giusto un po grazie a dio
ho studiato un po di geometria le
elementari alle medie e basse cioè
studiato è un parolone però vabbè 30 45
20 30 45 30 45 30 45 30.530 45 ho
trovato un oggetto chiave della cantina
ancora quanti chiama dop doc cosa cosa
cosa quale cantina ma abbiamo basta
quante porte mi fai aprire basta un film
son finite le porte non ce l'ho più il
pezzo blu mi serve una porta pezzo blu
il gatto ciò il gatto signor gatto lega
qui
spendo i pesci fa vj sedere spendo di
cache cache è un nome che possa far bene
in questo gioco signore la ringrazio
spento i pesci anche io li ho spesi per
quel gioco brutto che abbiamo fatto
insieme lei mi ha costretto pagato ben
98 centesimi e non si fa con gli amici
queste cose non si fanno signor gatto
viva pino grande fare continua così
grazie sarà usata la chiave della
cantina l'unica porta che mi
e con quando io vado in palestra la
gente così tutti sono tutti così sono
molto simpatici
allora ve li descrive tutti quello in
alto a destra e pietro quella sinistra
giampiero poi sotto vedo marco merlino
li nomino tutti questi figuri fine lei
la porta non mi avvicinerei la porta non
sapevo come lo ricordava anche a free
non ha fretta e si è aperto
mi seguirà anche il demonio adesso
immagino mi seguiranno tutti i meet me
li porto a casa no non mi hanno seguito
puzzo così tanto non l'avrei detto sono
contrariato però vabbè
no perché non chiudiamoci perché
partiamo subito a segreti di cui non mi
chiudo io vado ci vado attestando alle
cose fa le cose le faccio a testa
altissima perché io ci credo mica come
gli altri so io è il pezzo blu trovato
l'oggetto pezzo può adesso manca no
forse era meglio se mi chiudevo sì c'è
mancato un soffio ma ha risposto e
pericoloso andare in giro da soli posso
venire con te mi pare un'ottima idea
no no no no una donna quanto stupido e
ora l'ha fatto lui io non l'avrei mai
portato con me però vabbè poi col camice
rumore non so scritta la cosa non c'è
rumore non lo senti che non c'è rumore
ma che adesso c'e roma tra cure ai pezzi
ciglio tutti quindi adesso devo aprire
la porta che giustamente stato allora
salvo 1 a 2 metterli problemi ha visto
che non lo sapevo lo sapevo io e te lo
sei portato dietro come un deficiente è
colpa tua ma che poi si sono incastrate
fatto una cagata però vabbè jolo ha
fatto bene la mia giù molto bene che
culetto allora pezzo blu pezzo blu pezzo
blu papali trequartisti col però
sapevamo
mamma mia
no no no no no
no tra puro ammazzati sono uscito ho
vinto finito ho vinto io ho vinto io sei
scarso fai schifo pettinati ho vinto ho
corso e corso fino a tornare in città il
mostro non mi stava più inseguendo è un
film
ebbene caso piccioni quelli cos'era
quella cosa blu
non ne ho idea ma attaccare gli altri
sono ancora scomparsi e stessi gazzi
chi è questo cos'è sta roba trash che
tra chi era quello ma cos'è cos'era
ma chi era la mia che urlo virile that's
it toni molto bene sono soddisfatto ok
quindi abbiamo rigiocato da leoni è
stato veramente figo non mi ricordavo
niente c'è quasi niente almeno è sempre
bello ride tipo come quando ti riguardi
di anime e le serie tv dopo che l'hai
già viste no è sempre bello riti di
giocarci insomma tempo impiegato un'ora
e trentadue perché siamo in live da due
ore scusami non spendo mi tornano i co
non mi contano i torni come sono in live
da due ore e dieci com'è possibile che
sto giocando da 132 a nel senso che
un'ora e trentadue effettive quindi
senza contare i vicari caricamenti buono
capito va bene ti sembra si imposti nome
del protagonista come god mode e succede
god mode
posso dire che cosa è successo
beh
queste voci in una villa fuori città di
come avesse abitata da un mostro cosa è
successo scusami questa scritta takuro
sono scemo io non sto facendo niente
cosa che fa scusami cosa scritta god
mode ditemelo perché non capisco non mi
può prendere cielo prova un attimo per
curiosità perché non ho mai provato non
lo so già sono più veloce mi pare o
sbaglio io ma forse sono io che
sentiremo amico jolie e god mode cosa
che fa gode invincibilità ma dai
fratelli veramente riprovare aspetta
aspetta aspetta
no dai non ci credo che se mi toccano e
non non non mi fa niente spero che cosa
che invece li facciano qualcosa per cui
se le merita le botte però in quanto lì
non si apre manga l'armadio figure
adesso diamo ciao
spero che tu muori io non posso perché
sono indici no voglio provarlo scusatemi
e curdi sono curioso di vedere come
funziona trema trematore madre ma chi
aveva subito trovato l'oggetto chiara ok
fatemi vediamo solo curiosissimo
tuttavia devo dire che adesso mi arriva
in faccia io non mi fa niente
davvero
[Musica]
preso chiave della camera da letto
e vero che figata
allora sei proprio brutto in culo te ne
sei accorto anche tu dai che figata
gli arriva l'uccello vabbè comunque che
è un gioco molto simpatico mi è piaciuto
non me lo ricordavo fosse un partito la
carità prove mi piace sta cosa che che
scelgo no droga c'erano anche altre cose
vero tipo no non lo rifaccio tranquilli
come no no il caccia voglio era finito
basta grazie né pelo e alessandro per le
donazioni ce n'era un'altra roba di
codici che potevi usare in ogni aspetto
che lo cerco sonic codex ogni ma quanti
ce ne sono un sacco
la specie sono un sacco perché li leggo
block man
c'è la modalità a south park
i rossi in questa modalità il timer per
scrivere a c'è la modalità che theo
mostra con per quanto tempo ti ti
seguono nel gioco ci sono un sacco di
modalità va bene provo solo una che mi
incuriosisce un sacco soft park si
chiama cosa ci sono i tipi di south park
ma più sfigata non sapevo mai novo o
chiamare park o perché qui li sta cosa
non avevano provato a rega giuro ma sto
male è fighissimo
e come non ero mai accorto di sta roba è
fighissimo
ma dai sicuro è molto più carina ligi ha
mica averi chemical
takeshi takeshi non dovrebbe essere
kenny takeshi babette se davvero una
[ __ ] mia manor tradotto proprio
tutti i dialoghi sei davvero una
[ __ ] che partiva andiamo ragazzi e
me ne torno a casa pronti così
per finissimo perché non ho cercato così
è bellissimo
cosa le va bene è bellissimo sì e no
vabbè fermi o mio dio hanno ammazzato
mica brutti bastardi non deve starmi è
bellissimo ma no dai geniale per no
dovevo giocarlo così regala si muove
anche tu mi posso narciso è bellissimo
cavolo perché hanno giocato così e
geniale e geniale fighissimo veramente
figo vabbè basta
è bellissimo non lo sapevo giuro vabbè è
stato bello va bene ragazzi dai giudei
stato molto molto simpatico allora io vi
dico più avanti avrà intenzione
accenniamo perché non è più horror più
avanti nelle prossime settimane avrà
intenzione di port di non fare più le
live la domenica il pomeriggio le farò
la sera che è il tipo così dalle 21 non
21 e 30 dalle 21 alle 23 e 30
quindi due ore e mezza così che sia
accessibile un po tutti no non ne farò
una mai farò due la settimana più avanti
non adesso
questo mercoledì oh questo giovedì
adesso vediamo ne farò un'altra farò
un'altra live magari faccioni raoni se
vi va facciamoli raonic continuo
facciamo unirà honey nella prossima live
spero che la seguiate spero che questa
vi sia piaciuta
ci vediamo vi faccio sapere su instagram
seguitemi su instagram che lo sapete
schiacciata la campanella qua sotto del
canale per ricevere notifiche così a
meno quando vanno in live lo sapete
e come si dice e faccio e vi faccio
sapere se questo mercoledì o questo
giovedì
faccio due ore e mezza di nuovo dalle 9
alle 11 e mezzo più o meno giochiamo
anni leoni
vabbè ragazzi niente spero che vi sia
piaciuto
seguitemi sinistra roma che vi faccio
sapere quando faccio neroni e questa
domenica comunque ancora parola live il
pomeriggio di 5 ore quindi tranquilli
niente spero vi sia piaciuto come questa
la verità iata in montaggio ma nelle
live non si taglia purtroppo spero vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi consistenti
decisamente mi piace codici ha già
compiuto da descrizione se non si da
questi iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo dove
telecomando ecco ci siamo ad un prossimo
video ad una prossima da ragazzi